des informations mais que je garderai
pour moi parce qu'il ya une véritable
confidentialité autour de ce dossier et
chacun peut le comprendre ce qu on est
sur des enjeux financiers des enjeux de
concurrence commerciale assez important
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'effectivement
cette entreprise a fait le choix de
s'implanter ici sur le territoire du
grand chalon pour deux raisons je pense
majeures d'abord parce que notre région
est magnifiquement placé pour le sur le
plan logistique
c'est vrai que nous sommes à portée de
marché aussi bien français qu'étrangers
qui nous fait véritablement un avantage
comparatif énorme par rapport à d'autres
régions
et puis il ya un avantage aussi c'est
que nous avons ici à chalon et dans les
communes du grand chalon notamment sur
la zone sonore des réserves foncières et
quand vous avez un gros projet vous avez
besoin de plusieurs hectares parfois
pour le réaliser alors vous regardez un
petit peu ce qui est immédiatement
disponible
et bien finalement envoyé à chalon on
tire parti d'un terrible secousse une
terrible secousse économique qui s'est
tapé la fermeture de kodak
il ya maintenant une douzaine d'années
kodak a fermé c'était un tremblement de
terre économique colossal mais tout le
monde s'y est mis autour de la table
tout le monde a retroussé les manches et
finalement au bout de dix ans on se
retrouve avec ce site de kodak qui
deviennent formidable opportunité
foncière et qui permet d'accueillir des
projets de cette ampleur
donc je m'en réjouis énormément on a
déjà un taux de chômage qui est bas sur
le territoire du grand chalon de l'ordre
de 7%
c'est moins que la moyenne nationale et
cette création qui devrait concerner une
centaine d'emplois dans les médias et
qui si les choses vont bien pour être
porté à 200 poids est incontestablement
une bonne nouvelle pour toutes les
familles de la région